人類を改良するブッダの教え
はい これから皆様の役に立つブッダの教えのほんのわずか
今日はほとんど真面目に話しません
普通 私の講演はかなり厳しいんですが
まあ時間も結構取ったりしますし
今日はそんな時間もないしね
すぐ終わらないと時間を見ないと
あと 1時間しかない  58分しかないんです
で その教えのほんのわずかだけ紹介します
理性と現実性があれば
誰にでも理解できる ブッダの教えを理解するためには
理性さえあればいいんです
日本の方々には理性がないと言えませんしね
日本は現実主義じゃないとも言えませんし
ない人々も結構いますけどね
まあでも 大勢の方々は信仰は嫌いで
宗教も嫌いで まあ 1 日のことで忙しくて
すごく具体的 合理的に生きているんですよ
そういう方々にぴったし合うんですよ
心の安らぎをもたらしてくれるブッダの教えは
あの あれは信仰する これは信仰するっていうことは
まあ嫌な人々 現代人はほとんど嫌なんですね
例えば外国に行くときは
時々いろんな資料を書かなくちゃいけないんですね
外国ではレリジョンという項目がありますからね
それで日本の人々は面白いことに
3人でもうあまり英語でも書けないんだから
これどういう意味で これどういう
これをどう書くの？とか
お互い話し合ったら書きますから
じゃあレリジョンって何ですか？レリジョン
宗教ですけど と えっと
宗教に何書けばいいんでしょうかと
という風な話 だから外国人にとっても
なんだこれはと 宗教 宗教
何を書けばいいかと じゃあ我々は日本人だから仏教じゃないの？あ
そうです じゃあ仏教で書きましょうと
それで仏教って英語で何と言うんですかねとかね
そんな程度ですよ 宗教に対する興味は
それが私がすごくいいことだと思っているんです
もう批判的に言ってるわけじゃないんです
それが皆様のいいところなんです
あまり気にしない だからお釈迦様の教えはぴったし合うんです
何も気にしない お釈迦様
例えば日本で人気ある占いとかね
お守りとか あれやこれやとかね
除霊するとかね いろいろあるでしょ
あの推移なんとか学とかね
方位学とかね お釈迦様
あんなのはインチキいいがちなものだと
あんなのは畜生 畜生がやるもんだと
我々人類がやるもんや
それぐらいキャナステです
しかし 人間は畜生のごとく
金さえ入れば何でもやるんだよと
金が欲しければまともな立派な仕事をしろよと
コーヒー占いやったり
タロット占いやったり
はい  5,000円とかね
情けない だったら荷物でも運んであげてね
じゃあ 5,000円ちょうだいというのは
もうしっかりしたかっこいい仕事なんですよ
お釈迦様はそういう立場なんですよ
で 麻原が言ったことなんですけど
なんで自分が宗教を作りたいんだ
あれは商売を変えようかなとか
だからと思う そういう風なことっていうのは
かなり恥ずかしいでしょ
世界的に見ても しかし
日本人は世界で恥ずかしい民族じゃないんですよ
もうちょっと理性を育ててください
このお釈迦様の教え ちょっと勉強してください
世界一かっこいい人間になるんです
もう世界のリーダーになれるんです
何のことはない なぜならば
皆様本来持っている優しさ
理性に基づいて物事を考えること
日本の方々っていうのは
それほど差別意識はあるんですけど
僕はね もうそれほど差別意識は持ってないんです
あの学校とかそういうところでいじめがあるなどなどはあるんですけど
あんまり世界的にはそんなに差別意識を持ってないんですよ
だから本当に私が個人的な主観では
世界でやっぱりリーダーになる資格があるのは日本人じゃないかなと
もう科学的にも先端にいるし
もう世間 世間的な信心を見ても先進国であるし
別に誰でも 2番目になる必要はないんですよ
アメリカにもよろよろ
これ 2番目どころじゃないんで
18番目から 23番目とか
時々ガタガタが出ちゃうとかなり低い位置なんです
これが聞くとすごく嫌な気分になる
なんで 1か 2にならないんだ
皆様 例えば この第3世界の国々に援助をするということになると
日本はかなり苦労しながら結構いいんです
します 日本の国家国民の収入とか経済状況から私が判断すると
これって結構無理やってるんじゃないかなと思いますよ
しかし 立場がないんですね
全部他の国々に持っていかれるんですよ
これってあんまり良くない
やっぱり第三世界の貧しい国々を助けてるならば
いつでもトップに来るのは日本ではないかというふうに言われるように
何か精神的なリーダーシップが欲しいんですよ
だから この曖昧中途半端でいつでも後ろに下がっているところは
なんとかブッダの教えを教えてあげて直したいんです
という余計なことですね
で ブッダの教えのワンポイント
今日はあんまり喋りません
一つはアニッチタ これは私は日本語訳を無常性と訳したんです
パーリ語でアニッチタって読むんです
アニッチタとは無常であることです
意味は無常であること
この無常と無常であることというのは意味が違うんです
すべては無常だというより
微妙にニュアンスが違いますよ
無常であること 生きている上では
すべての現象は無常であることを念頭にして生きることをお釈迦様は勧めるんです
それが苦を乗り越える道になるんです
これ スリランカの仏教というお釈迦様の教えの大事なポイント
あの対・・・地球が太陽を回り回っているような感じで
仏教はこの無常というポイントに回り回っているんです
中心にして で これってすごいことなんですよ
で 時々人々は仏教は 特に新しい人々はね
仏教はね 何でも無常と言うんだから
仏教徒っていうのは暗くて努力しない連中やと
我々西洋の宗教はもう無常は認めませんだからしっかり頑張ってるんだと
って言うんだけど 私の反論は
あなた方はね 鉄砲を持って機関銃を持って人の国を侵略して
独裁 独占的な商売して
何か開発したら それは一人占めにして
いわゆる泥棒して盗んで強盗してヤクザみたいに豊かになってるだけでしょうと
俺が強盗してすごい金持ちやと
これ自慢にできるでしょうかと
いう私の反論なんです
で お釈迦様も何でも無常ですから
どうしようもないと落ち込むというのはとんでもないけしからんことやと説かれているんですよ
それで無常の見方があるんだから
時々仏教は悲観主義だ
悲観主義だと言われることがありますけど
悲観主義の悪い 皆さんも行ってみてください
タイでもよろしいし スリランカに行くのは一番ありがたいんですけど
あんまりスリランカじゃなくて
魚釣ったり 海に潜ったりしたくて
モルディブ諸島に行くんですね
あんな小さなところに行くよりスリランカに行った方がいいのにね
結婚したら若者が もっと人間見た方がいいんですよ
だから結婚している若者たちはほとんどみんなモルディブ諸島に行くんですよ
で エアランカというか
あの 何て言いましたか
あれはね 今スリランカって言うんですけど
それ会社もまあもう一応人が乗ってくるんだから運ぶんだけど
もうちょっとモルディブ諸島よりはスリランカの方がいいんだよと
もう初めて結婚した夫婦にとっては
人間はどんなものでも穏やかでニコッと笑って乗り越えるべきだよということを学んだ方がいいんじゃないんですか
海に潜って魚釣ったりしてね
それよりは とは思いますけど
とにかく皆様方 スリランカに行ったり
ミャンマーに行ったり
タイに行ったり 見てください
無常で生きている人々なんですけど
みんな笑っているんです
泣かないんです で 私の印象にあったある画像があって
これはタイのものなんです
NHKかどこかでニュースで流れたもので
テレビですごく雨が降って
ものすごい大洪水になっちゃって
タイは それでみんなの家の屋根上まで水が上がっちゃってして
家はほとんど潰れて そうすると小さなボートなんかでも人をもう救済するんですよ
あの それで小さなボートにも家が潰れてるの
子供たちがみんな乗ってキャーキャーとこうやって手を振ったり
カメラに手を振ったり笑ったりとかね
あれ見たらこれほども家が潰れてるわ
もう命拾いしてるところなんですよ
やっぱりそれでも あ これって面白い
楽しいやと 洪水になっても
普通車が走る道路なのに
今ボートで行くんだぞとかね
だからこの この明るさはね
私も感動しますよ 本当に
日本に長く居すぎちゃってね
もうすぐ暗くなっちゃう
だから ああいう人々の顔を見て
まあもうちょっとふざけた方がいいんじゃないかなと
人生はとと思ったりする
そういうことだから 決してこの無常ということは悲観主義ではありません
無常性っていうのは現実です
事実です 事実を認めることは
誰が悲観というんですかね
物事は絶えず止まることなく変化し続けるのです
変化をし続けるのです
このダイナミズムを無常という単語で表現しています
これ 科学的な事実ですよ
皆様は知ってますかね？原子一個でも止まらないんですよ
中はググッと動いてます
エネルギーが まあ原子っていうのはあんまり物体か何かわけもわからないもので
エネルギーなんですね
だからエネルギーっていうものは止まらないんですよ
だから何ものも止まらない
もう変わる 変わる 変わる
変わるということが無常性なんですね
無常性だからこそ生きるんです
それで我々は元気で生きてるんだってことはどういうことですかね
無常がなかったら大変なことになりますよ
ご飯食べても食べても
そのまんま石を飲み込んだことになりますよ
死にますよ ご飯食べたらご飯は無常だからすぐ溶けてなくなっちゃいます
その栄養は細胞に入って
細胞は働いて それまた消えていきます
で またご飯食べる楽しみがあるんじゃないんですかね
もし赤ちゃんが無常でなければ
もうもう五年六年経ってもまだ抱っこしなくちゃあかんと思ったら
考えてみてください お母さんたち知ってるでしょ
赤ちゃん一年間どれぐらい苦しいかと
育てるのに一日八回ぐらい
時々十回 十二回ぐらいおっぱいあげなくちゃいかんから
いくらおっぱい吸っても大きくならなきゃどうします？大変でしょ
だからもうみるみるうちに大きくなって
またもうもうまたもう一歳にもなってないくせにも立とうと歩こうとしてるでしょ
すぐハイハイしようとするしね
これが楽しいんですよ
子供が赤ちゃんが立とうとしてやっと立ったところでまたこけますけど
やっぱり最高の幸せなんですよ
あれが みんな写真撮ったりして
これ思い出に 親だけなんですけど
もう覚えとくんですね
だからこれが無常の楽しみなんですよ
しかし 自分の子供は立とうとするとまたこけちゃう
立てようとするとまたこけちゃう
これ 1ヶ月間続けたらどうなるんですかね
同じ現象が 大変ですよ
それだったらもう心配で堪らなくなっちゃいますよ
で 赤ちゃんが一回立ってこけて
また一回立ってこけて 3
回目しっかり立つんです
それからこけながら歩き出すんですよ
そこでこの絶えず起こる変化が面白いんですよ
それが楽しいんですよ
それが生きることなんです
だから 我々大人よりは子供の方がものすごく面白いのは
毎日変化なんですね 毎日変化する
だからそのスピード変わらないんですよ
皆様も赤ちゃん の時と同じく変化しているはずなんですよ
同じスピードで でもどう見たって面白くないんですね
年の方々は これって何でしょうかね
何でしょうかというと
この変化嫌なんですね
変です 頭が ちょっと何か変わったら
ああ 大変だ 嫌だ どうしようかとかね
変わるのは当たり前でしょうに
これ変わることが期待なんです
期待すれば人生は楽しいんですよ
何にももうめげることなく
すくすくと進んでいけます
そういうわけで 人間は成長するわ
努力は叶ったりするわ
あるいは叶わなかったりするわ
すべて無常という流れの結果なんです
時々みんな勉強したりしてね
もう成長するでしょうに
時々成長の代わりに退化する人を見ますね
もう結構会社を作って
収入も得て豊かなんですけど
後で賭け事やらいろんな遊びに手を出して
もうちょっと傲慢になったりして
俺の金は消えるはずがないんだと言って大借金になっちゃって
会社まで倒産してしまう場合もあるし
だからすべて無常なんですよ
小さな会社 大会社に発展することも
大会社が一瞬に一瞬にして潰れることも無常の流れなんです
それでお釈迦様が推薦するのは
変わることを変えることにしましょうと
原因と条件があるから
絶えず物事は変わるんです
どうせ変わるんですよ
それなら変えることはできるんです
だから変わることを放っておけば
私たちにはどうすることもできなくなるんです
だから どうせ変わる 変え変わるものは
お釈迦様が変えなさいよと言うんです
例えば トマトっていうのは人間の食べ物でしょ
あの昔のトマトっていうのは酸っぱくて
もうレモンと同じ味でしたからね
しかし 今のトマトは果物か野菜かわからないでしょ
私はちっちゃな時は 小さい時はトマトなんか生で食べるものだと想像できなかったんです
酸っぱいんですよ だからいろいろ香辛料とかいろいろ入れて料理作るんです
あるいは料理の味を引き立てるために使ったんです
これ 日本に来てみたら
まあリンゴ食べるよりはトマトを食べた方が美味しいし
柔らかいしね 変えたんでしょ？トマト
だから無常でなきゃできると思いますか？だから無常っていうのは現実であって
本当に役に立つ教えですよ
よく無常であることを覚えておきなさいよと
だから人生失敗したっても大丈夫だ
全部無常だからこれから変えますよというふうにポジティブ的に人生を見るんですよ
無常を知っている人は
あーどうしよう どうしようではなくて
何とかできます だから例えば地震が起きて家が潰れたら
どうしよう 私の家なんで潰れたんだろう
なんで潰れたんだろう
悩んで悩んで PTSD にまでなるでしょう
あれは無常を否定するからなんです
スリランカではもう歴史上
津波が一回しか 二回起きたっていうことですが
誰にも もうこれはかなり昔
で それあまりわからないんですけども
最近ものすごい人々が亡くなりになったけど
あまり PTSD になる人はないと思いますよ
しかし キリスト教の人々やら
NGO の方々とかも わざとその現象を作って
こういう後遺症の人々は作ってあげなくちゃいけない
組織作らなくちゃいけない
あれは自分の宗教を教えたがっているんですよ
神様の教えを教えちゃうと
なおさら病気になりますけどね
で だってなんで神が全知全能でこんなとんでもないことをするのかと聞きたくなりますからね
やっぱり仏教の人々は
どうしようどうしようではなくて
何とかしようと明るいんですよ
でもう一つ思い出すエピソードがあります
この津波が起きた時は起きて
もうみんなもう避難してたくさん
で その様子を見るために
総理大臣ですね そちらへに行ったというニュース
新聞にあった話なんですね
行ってみんなの状況と
それから大人たちはあれやこれやこうなった
家はこれぐらい 何人か死にましたとか
いろいろ報告して ものすごく喋ると
そうするとそこら辺にちっちゃな男の子がいたんだと
いたら その男の子もちっちゃな男の子
何のことなく総理大臣のところに行って
あの 私のお母さん 両親
お母さんもみんな亡くなっちゃったんだよと
家も潰れたんだよと 私はどうすればいいんですかと
総理大臣ちょこちょこと直接聞く
言ったら その総理大臣がその子供を膝の上に座ってもらって
もう君は心配することはないんだと
何も心配することはない
全部面倒見てあげるからということで約束したんだそうです
あれ聞いたら 私はこの子はすごいなと
あれほどもう総理大臣というのはテロリストいる国だからね
なかなか結構厳しいんですよ
警備やらなんてわかんない
何のことなく だから別にお母さんが亡くなったんだとか
泣いたりするんじゃなくて
じゃあどうしようと これからやること
ちっちゃい時から だからこの無常っていうのは
明るい社会を作るために必要な教えであって
これは信仰しないでください
事実ですからね 地球が丸いと誰が信仰するんですかね
これは事実ですよ だから無常っていうのは信仰しなくて大丈夫です
それは事実です だからお釈迦様が言うのは
変えなさい 変えなさい
変えなさいと 成長しなさいということで
人生をより良い方向へ変えることは
ブッダが人類に解く戒めなんです
生命を不幸に陥れる脅す言葉は
ブッダの教えに一切ないんです
私を信じなきゃ汝らは地獄に落ちる
全然ないんですよ バカバカらしくて
で これ断言できます 仏教とはブッダが正しいという立場を決して変えません
で だからってスリランカ人みんなブッダがお釈迦様がおっしゃっている通りに生きているかというと
それはすごい違います
もうやっていることとお釈迦の教えを見ればかなり隔たりがありますが
ブッダが正しいというスタンスだけは変えません
私はダメですけど ブッダの教えが正しいんだと
酒飲みながら やっぱりこれはお釈迦様はまずいやと
罪やと飲むなよと言ってますよと
これは知ってます 逆をしませんが
お釈迦の教えを変えようとしようとしません
これ大乗仏教は自分がだらしなくなると
教えそのものを変えようとするんですね
それは恐ろしいことで
やってはいけない非科学的なことで
で 自分がダメならダメでいいんですよ
人間は別に だからで教えまで変える必要はないんですよ
スリランカ人っていうのは
酒飲みたいの酒飲みますけど
やっぱり私は仏教徒なんですけど
まあこれは仏教ではやってはいけないことであると
これははっきりしています
だからその点では  仏教の教えは壊れません
スリランカ人誰でもみんな今現代酒飲むんだから
この五戒の5番目を取り消しましょうよとは言わないんです
たまたま言う人がいるんですけど
跡形もなく消えます もう 1週間ぐらい喋りますから
みんなにクタクタ批判されちゃって終わります
それはできません 時々いるんですよ
もう誤解はもうなんで朝も晩も昼も受けますかと
若いお坊さんたちも時々いるんですよ
頭イカれちゃってね もう
なんでいつでも誤解を受けるんでしょうかと
誤解は一生一回受けたら十分ではないかと
そう言うのは 1ヶ月間ぐらい言いふらしますけど
おばさんたちに怒られちゃってね
あのお坊さん いい加減にしなさいよと言われると黙ってるんです
で 我々は朝も晩もいつでも誤解を受けますと
だから若い人々は言うのはもう誤解を受けるだけでも守らないんではないかと
これがいくらなんでも守りにくいところはあることありますし
だから破れるたびにまた誤解を受ける
だからかなり自信と覚悟が必要ですよ
誤解を守るためには だから誤解はもう人間弱いんだから
たまたま破ってしまっても
またまたまたまた繰り返しそれを受けたりして
我々はブッダの教えを実践する者であることはいつでも自覚して生きていることっていうのは一つの文化なんです
はい 変える時 規則があるんです
例えばトマトをカボチャに変えることはできませんよ
トマトをものすごく甘くすることはできますし
でっかいトマトを作ることもできるし
プチトマトを作ることもできます
しかし トマトはカボチャにしようかなと思ったら
形が似ているんだからできるんじゃないかな
でもこれはできません
やっぱり変える場合もいろいろ規則があります
老いること 病に陥ること
死ぬことは避けられない
覚えておきなさいと これは誰でも覚えておかなくちゃいけないんですよ
皆様のよくよく私が聞く話を聞く場合は
このこのなんか病に陥ること
死ぬこと 老いることをなんとかしてくれないかというふうに思ったりしますけど
これは何にもなりませんよ
それ嫌がると極限に苦難に陥るんです
これがかわいそう お医者さんにもどうにもならないんですよ
だからまあ病気になったらなったで
まあそんなのは当たり前
誰が気にするもんかと
じゃあ治療してやるぞと
治療したお医者さんが
いえ これは治りません
あ そう じゃあまあいいやと
どうったことはないんだと
そんなのはと 自然原則法則やといて
明るくいることだけは決して忘れないんですよ
病気で痛くて苦しいんだけど
心が明るい そうすると看病する人も楽しいし
お医者さんも楽しいし
明るい患者さんだと そういうことで
この我々は現実を嫌がるんだから
極限に苦難に陥るんですね
楽に生きられる範囲で生活
を管理したり 収入を得たりするんです
まあ我々はまあ楽に まあほどほど生きられるぐらい収入あればよろしいし
まあほどほど人生管理して
あんまりの食べ過ぎにもならないで
まあ適当な量を食べて
適当な量楽しんで遊んで
この量を知った方がよろしいんです
そういう風に 例えばグルメに
何て言いますか 執着しようと思っちゃうと楽じゃないんですよ
グルメオタクになっちゃうと人生が苦しいんですよ
世界中グルメを探しながら歩き回らなくちゃいけないし
意味がないしね 体が病気になるし
バカバカらしいんですね
食うことだけ人生だってこと
そうではなくても ほどほどに美味しく食べて
あんまりそれにそんなに走り回らない
で ゲームセンターでパチンコやってもいいんですけど
まあほどほど  1週間 30 分とか 1時間とか行って
毎日あの毎日 3時間行かなくちゃいけないって
そんなは病気なんですね
で あるいはもう当たるまでやるぞとかね
そういう変なことは仏教は否定するんです
だからいつでもほどほどで
楽に生きることを考えてくださいと
あの いろいろ落とし穴に陥らないことを気をつけなさいよということで
次に 心を成長しないで
ものの発展だけを目指す現代人の生き方に疑問を持つんです
特にスリランカでもタイでもミャンマーでもよく喋ると
だからミャンマーの人々が言ったら
あなた方はこのもう国を閉鎖しちゃってね
すごい成長止まってるでしょうと
いわゆる私は言ったことあるんですよ
なんだこれはと すっごくもう時代遅れになってるんではないかと言ったら
それはわかりますけど
あまり大胆に隣のタイみたいにはなりたくないんだと
なんでもかんでも現代的にはなりたくないんだと
それちょっと疑問に考えるんですね
例えば もう何でも何でも開発
開発 発展とか言いつつ
現代どうなってるんでしょうかというと
飲み水まで汚染しちゃって
海ももう汚染しちゃって
あの 昨日のテレビで昨日か一昨日見たんですけど
もう大変ですよ 日本の周りの海も
もうサンゴ礁は死ぬわ
もう熱帯のところにいる魚たちが上上がってくるわ
毒性のある微生物はどんどん生えるわ
魚が死ぬわもう魚の体にも毒が生えるわ
もう生きていられなくなってるんでしょうね
世界は温暖化にしたのは仏教徒ではありませんよ
だからもうなんあったまが悪いんですよ
何でももう潰して潰して
その時儲ければいいという
この現代科学的な思想
すべて壊しちゃったんで
科学者っていうのはもう面白いんです
頭の悪さは 昨日も一人
お年の科学者に会いましたけど
天文学者で 私は 彼がすごいことと言ったことはね
科学はね もうもうあなた方は人間中心に考えているんだと
科学はもう今 最近 生命
動植物を一緒に考えているんだと
なんかお前びっくりだろと口先で
私はアホじゃないかという心の中で
この人何やとという気持ち
まあ年上だから何も言わなかったんですけど
できるだけ向こうの価値になるように喋りましたけど
で しかし天文学だから私はね
あのね お釈迦様  2200年前でね
この宇宙は収縮することを膨張することは何なんとなく語られて
そんなことはありません
できるわけないんだと偉そうに断言するんですね
それで後で言うんです
私に 私は仏教といえば般若心経しか読んだことはないんだよと言ったら
私は先生 私は般若心経について本を書いていますから
読んでみたらいかがでしょうかと
本のタイトルを般若心経は間違いであると
だからそんな程度のことで
見ようともしない 調べようともしないで否定する科学っていうのは何だと
俺はと 化石燃料を取って燃やすと自然が変わるんだっていうぐらいわからないんですかね
原子爆弾を合成すると
これで放射能ですごいことになるんだそうと
この連中わからないんですよ
だからまあ 仏教徒は科学者がすごく偉いと自慢するんです
我々は人類の幸福のために物事を考えるんだと
競争ではなくて共存しましょうと
カラスは生きていられない
スズメが生きていられない状況だったら
人間は気をつけろよと
私はどこでも水たまりを見るとよく見るのは
何か小さな生命がいるか否かと
あっちこっちギュギュッとして生命がいると安心するんです
あ 綺麗やと で 自分のお寺でちょっとしたタンクを作って魚飼ってるんです
でっかい魚なんですけどね
なんで飼ってるのかと
あの魚たちは自分が魚とわからないんです
私と同じく頭が悪いんです
人間だと思ってるんです
だから遊ぶはふざけるは
で この間遊び遊んだ ちょっと失敗して私の指も噛んでしまったんですけど
抱っこすることもできます
何か水の上から抱っこじゃ死にますけどね
気にしないんです だからあまり遊ばないんですけど
私は信者さんがお布施でケーキとか持ってきたら
一部魚さんに持っていくんです
魚にあげたら パクッと食べたら
あ これはいいケーキだ
食べましょうと食べるんです
時々魚がふんという感じであっち向くんです
まあいい 結構やと もう食べないんです
だからやっぱり商売で作るものだから
何入れてるかわからないし
体に良くないものをいろいろ入れたりしてね
防腐剤やらいろんなものを入れてるでしょうね
魚は食べませんだからもうそれで身の安心
そういうことで このやっぱりみんなと一緒に生活した方がよろしいんじゃないかなと思う
蚊はめんどくさいんですけど
これだからできるだけ家の周りとか
まあそれスリランカ人に言わなくちゃいけないんですけどね
きれいにしておけば 体に悪い蚊は成長しませんですけど
で 心 だから我々仏教の国々は
このでっかい空の雲まで建物を作ることではなくて
どこかバーレンとかね
もう我ら世界一バカやというために世界一建物を作ってるんですよ
あのお金で自分のイスラム教の国々の人々は飢えていますけど
あげたらどうですかね
いろいろ工場を作ってあげたり
学校を作ってあげたりしたらどうですかね？何やってるんですかね
あの十階 十二階のビルまで上がる
あのでっかい噴水 あれはもう 100 エイカーとか
ものすごい大きいんですよ
水はもう十二階 ビルの十二階まで上上がるように作ったりして
もともと国が砂漠ですけど
ああいうのはもう直行で地獄に落ちる罪なんですよ
仏教から見れば だって石油からお金入るかもしれません
そのお金は世界 地球の人類をあげているんでしょうに
だったら我々には来なくてもいいんです
自分の宗教を信仰する人々を助けてあげたらいかがでしょうかと
だから仏教の場合は こんなくだらない発展よりは心の成長の方が大事だよという立場をとるんです
心は基本的に無常を認めない
ですから 認識に根本的な間違いがあります
みんなの頭はおかしいんです
我々気持ち的には無常は認めたくないんです
皆 より良い世界を築く努力はするが
苦しみが増えることはあっても減ることはありません
ですから 頭がおかしいんだからね
無常を認めないんですよ
我々の努力はいかにして無常を止めるかと
いかにして年取ることがやめられるかという医学者が研究するんですよ
そうすると人類はなくなってしまいますよ
年取らなきゃダメなんですよ
で 病気は完全に無くすことができればという夢の物語があるんですよ
今も証拠できてますよ
細菌とかなんとかとかいた方がいいんだと
何の薬も効かない 抗生物質に物質の効かないバクテリアたちがものすごい早く開発して変化していくんですよ
しかし それを退治する薬がなかなか出てこないんです
薬一つ 新しい抗生物質開発するためには
まあ五 六年 七 八年かかりますし
それにはなかなか儲からないんだから
薬を作っている会社は作れないし
で 政府もお金を出してくれないし
だから古い抗生物質ばっかりでやろうとしますけど
最近現れてくるバクテリアなんかはもう薬も効かないとかね
例えば結核っていうのは簡単に治ると思っていたんですけど
今 抗生物質効かない細菌が
バクテリアが出てきて
もうどうしようもないというね
で マラリアもいとも簡単に治れますけど
今のマラリアを作る あの
なんたかなんとかものはもうなかなか薬が効かないとかね
そういうことだから 人類から病気を消してしまいますとか
何言ってるんですかね
この非現実的な人たちが
やっぱり共存の方がいいんですよ
そういうことで 現代的な心を無視してやってる発展では
人間が退化して堕落して危ないことになるっていうのは仏教の立場なんです
この矛盾は無明をアヴィッチャーという言葉で表現します
だ飛ばします で 心の成長ということ
無常を素直に認められるように無明を足すことが心の成長です
だから無常を認めましょうと
そんなのは当たり前やと
それだったら我の生き方
いきなり変わるんですよ
何でも無常と取っちゃうと
今の瞬間しか人生がないんだとわかると
今の瞬間で悩んだり 怒ったり
人と人のことを何といいますか
嫉妬したり 恨んだりしない
もったいないんですよ
人生は 瞬間瞬間生きてて年取っていくでしょ
だからその瞬間 その瞬間
明るく楽しく生きていられます
闇雲に生きることに挑戦して
くたびれて惨めに負けて死ぬよりは
無明を断って智慧を開発することが人生の勝利だとする
仏教とは 生きることにしがみつくことなく
気楽に生きるんです 飛ばします
次の別なポイント 無常の話はそこで終わりです
無常を認める人っていうのは
ものすごい元気で明るいんです
ブッダは生命とは何なんかと
その真理を語るが 道徳と実践は当然人間中心なのです
これちょっと言葉難しいんです
仏教っていうのは生命論なんです
生命科学なんです 生命とは何かと見事に分析して
そのシステムを教えているんです
これはもう誰にも違いますと言えないんです
すごい真理なんです いまだに現代知識の世界では生命に定義はありません
昨日の講演で私は生命の定義はささささと言ってあげたんですが
あの科学に頭がおかしくなってた先生は
その話終わってから やっぱり生命の定義はできません
それあれやこれやと 何も話を聞いてないみたいですね
それはできないことはすごいことであると言って
なんだ信じられない 誰かアホの話を持ってきて喋ります
私はまあこれは諦めた方がいいやだなと言ったんです
しっかりした定義持ってます
仏教は 今日は時間ないんです
しかし 仏教が語る悪はすべての生命に対しても悪です
私が言いたいのは お釈迦様がおっしゃっている道徳
実践というのは人間に語っています
犬に語っていないので
嘘をつくなよとは犬に言わないんです
もともと嘘をつかないしね
私が飼っている犬たちは一応ごまかそうとはしますけど
で 私の影響で 普通は犬
犬に嘘をつくなよというふうに意味がないでしょうね
嘘をつくなよっていうのは
人間には語ってますが
嘘をつくことは良くない
それ悪行為であることはすべての生命には普遍的なんです
輪廻を脱出するために
たとえ神であっても無明を破らなくてはならないんです
神であろうともしょうがないんです
修行して無明を破らないと幸福にはなれません
これ 生命平等というポイントについて
ちょこっと違うポイントを紹介したいんです
生命にサッタという言葉を使います
仏教が 衆生有情という訳語があります
生きとし生けるものという意味なんです
訳語で意味がわからないんだからね
生けるものっていうこと
感覚があるものは生命です
これは一つの定義なんです
例えば このテーブルは生命ですかと言えば生命ではありません
なぜならば感覚がないんです
私は生命ですかと言えば生命です
なぜならば感覚があるんです
だから ミミズも何でもかんでも感覚あるものは生命です
それがサッターということで
理論的には生命は平等ですが
実際には一人一人が違います
だから仏教は観念的に生命は平等だ
人間は平等だとか どんないい加減なことは言いません
言うのは理論的には平等ですが
実際は一人一人違いますよと
倫理的に見ると 個が自分を中心にして他人を評価するんです
そこで生命は平等やと言い張る前に
個人を見ると 私が私を中心にして他の生命のことを見ているんです
それでどうなるのかというと
それで差別意識が起こるんです
自分と他人が同じ 他人が劣っている
他人が自分より優れているという 3種類の魔が生じて心が汚れるんです
人をいじめたり 差別したり
人に支配されたりするんです
その生き方は真理に合わないので
新たな苦しみ 問題などが生じるんです
だから自己中心にして
自分が基準にして世の中のことを判断するんだから
もう変もいいところなんですよ
それであの人偉いんだと思っちゃうと
自分が惨めになったりする
あの人はなんだ あの人はと思っちゃうと
自分がすごい まあなんて言いますか
偉いと思ってしまっちゃいますね
そういう傲慢になったりする
そういうことで精神的に病気になったり
かなりの問題を起こすんですよ
それで我々人類がお互いに喧嘩したり
いろんなトラブルが起こるんです
平等であることは発見するんです
生命は平等だと言い張るんじゃなくて
科学者ごとく実験して発見してほしいんです
個には自我 エゴという錯覚がある
仏教とはこの錯覚をなくすために
生命は平等であることを発見し
経験するまで心育てるんです
これは慈しみの実践として
ブッダの教えを実践する人の基本的な修行です
スリランカの場合は小さな子供たちからも始まるんですよ
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにという言葉を知らない人はいません
で 幼稚園の子供たちもなんとか知っていて
もう間違いながら読むんです
それでいつでも口ずさんで
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにという国の言葉で
我々は唱える 皆さんも講演が始まる前に唱えていましたね
これが仏教の基本的な修行なんですよ
一切の生命が幸福でありますようにという生き方
この区別を認めて 生命は平等であると理解できるまで成長するんです
だから 私は私で あなたはあなたで違うんだけど
一切の生命は平等であると
私は男で あなたは女で
これは全く同一ということになりませんだけど
生命としてはみんな平等
しかし お互いの区別も理解して認めましょうと
それで社会に対する影響
信仰の違い 生活習慣の違い
色や形の違いなどは 仏教徒にとっては当然で当たり前です
こんなものは潰そうと思わないんです
いろいろ信仰があると
生活習慣はそれぞれ人間は違いますよと
ご飯好きな人もいて ご飯嫌いな人もいるし
ご飯嫌いな人とあんた何だ
変だとか言わないんです
これは頭がおかしい人だけ言うんですよ
ご飯とおかずを一緒に食べる人もいて
別々に食べる人もいる
ご飯先に食べておかずを後から食べる人もいて
おかずを先に食べてご飯後回しにする人もいるし
いいんじゃないか それそれぞれ勝手に
そういう風に物事を見るんですよ
仏教徒は だからトラブルが起こらないんですよ
肌の色が黒い人がいて
白い人がいて これで面白いんですよ
それは当然にするんで
当然のことだと 他人に強引に考え
信仰を押し付けることなく
軽蔑することなく 非難することなく
調和を仲良くすることを強調するんです
ブッダの教えは これ大事なところなんです
我々は人を軽蔑することはとんでもない罪だと思っています
脅されてますよ あなたは否定
人を軽蔑すると 死後 犬猫やら動物になって
野良犬野良猫になっちゃって
みんなに貶される羽目になりますよと
だから気をつけろよと
誰であっても生命平等っていうふうに見るべきだと
私も小さい時 母に脅されたことあります
だから仏教徒は一生懸命考えるのは
どうすればこの人と仲良くなれるのかと
どうすれば仲良くなれるのか
それだけなんですね 人を傷つけることは決して良くないんだというような
仏教的な 仏教の基本的な生き方なんですね
だから皆様疑問を持ってるでしょうね
だったらあなたは何なのかと
この話はとかね  これは私はちょっと特別な人間で
スリランカのお坊さんたちは結構人を傷つけないし
断言的な物事を言わないしね
私はもう堂々とハッナ神宮間違いだと言うんですけど
スリランカのお坊さんたちはあんまりそういうことは言いません
しかし 悪を否定する 非難する
まあ何でもいいやと仏教徒は思ってますけど
悪に限っては断言的に批判するんです
悪いことは悪いんだよと
あなた 神様はキリスト教の神様を信仰したってもよろしいし
アッラーという神様を信仰したってもよろしいし
お犬様を信仰したってもどうぞご勝手に
しかし 人殺すなよと 生命殺すなよというところをはっきりするんです
この特色は社会に強いインパクトを与えるんです
だから仏教の影響っていうのはものすごく強いんです
誰とも仲良くするのは楽しいので
仏教は他宗教の攻撃を受けても壊しにくいものになっているんです
スリランカというのはイギリス人に支配されちゃったんですよ
植民地になっちゃったんです
あれほど力ある西洋イギリス人が
仏教はこったぐったく壊してやるぞと頑張ったんですけど
結局イギリス人が仏教徒になって話は終わったんです
排他的で 自分の神以外の信仰者たちは悪人だと決める
他宗教の人々も結局は仏教の影響を受けてしまうんです
生きとし生けるものは幸福でありますようにと念じる仏教徒には
神よ 我を救いたまえは意味を持たないんです
それで現代と未来 利己と競争をもとにして
現代社会の発展は一つの問題を解決して複数の新たな問題を作るんです
すべての生命に生きる権利がある
地球の資源は独り占めにするのは悪行為です
一人一人が自分に必要な資源以外使用してはならない
他人に差をつけるために必要以上に財産を貯めてはならない
いわゆる見栄を張ってはならないということ
能力がある人にたくさんの財産が入るならば
それは他人の豊かになれない人のために使用する分です
この間は自分のお寺の信者さんの一人の若い人がいて
で さっささっさと商売とかいろいろ手を出して
かなり金持ちになったんです
で すごい金持ちになっちゃって
しかし今は結構社長みたいな気分で
結構豊かなんですけど
人々は全然昔と同じく
もうもう普通に喋ったり
普通に挨拶したり でっかい家作ってますけど
誰でも好き勝手に入ったりとかね
なんのことないんですよ
この間見たら いろんな人々がもうもう仕事できない人やら
いろんな問題あって どこかで仕事を見つからないというような
みんなそういうところですごい元気よく明るく働いているんです
だからこの人は給料上げてるのに
社長に言いたいことを言ったりとかね
すごく仲良く兄弟のごとく仕事をしているのを見て
私はすごいなと感心したんですよ
やっぱりより豊かになったら
その分はみんなのために
できない人を助けるために使うべきなんですよ
それでちょっと障害がある人が
ちょっと認識的に仕事に就かない
だから親には何の収入はない
男の人はちょっと問題があって
その人はその若者を雇ったんですよ
雇ったんですけど まあできるだけのことしてくださいと
できる範囲のことで それで本人もいろいろちょっとちょこちょこ仕事を頼む
それ気持ちよく 楽しくて
もう可愛いんです 見たらね
で 楽しくて言う通りにやってあげたりする
それでこの人が この社長が
やっぱりこの人々はね
これではいくら頑張ってもね
まあ家がなかった 住むところは
ちょっとしたハットを作ってなんとか生活して
それだったら私が家作ってあげるそうと言って家を作ってあげたんですよ
それを立派に作ってあげて
で 私に家を作ってあげて
本人に渡しますから ちょっと法要
法要をやりましょうと
そういう人々にも説法を聞いて
これから徳を積んで豊かになれるようにということで
祝福に祝福をかなって法要しましょうと言って
私も夜行ってね その家に家みたいに見たら
タダで作ってあげる家なのに
なかなか立派な家を作ってあげて
だからやっぱり人はそのために金持ちにならなくちゃあかんではないかとすごく思ったんですよ
だからそれは仏教の立場なんですよ
という仏教的な生き方は
現代を生きる人とこれから生まれる人に必要だと思う
だから何でもかんでも金持ちになろうではなくて
能力があって いろんな新しいものを開発したところで
もうむちゃくちゃ金が入り込んでいるならば
その余分分はやっぱり人類のために使うべきなんです
そうでなきゃ罪なんです
超越した境地 まあこれは飛ばした方がいいと思いますけど
生きることは苦である
渇愛は苦の原因である
渇愛を取り除くことは究極の幸福である
八正道はその方法であるというブッダの真理が四つあります
という聖なる真理を実現する人は
ただ生きて死ぬだけで終わらないんです
生きる目的 倫理的に生きる目的はないんです
論理的に なぜ生きるのかと誰も知らないのは
目的が存在しないからです
しかし 仏教徒には解脱するべきだという超越した目的があるので
現代に生きる人々に見られる精神的な病
曖昧な生き方 暗さ 娯楽に溺れることなどはないので
仏教徒は微笑んで生きているんです
以上です では 長い時間どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]